good afternoon everyone
uh my name is dr angie ambers and i'm
the assistant director of the henry c
lee institute of forensic science in
westhaven connecticut
and i'm going to be talking to you today
about
a post-conviction
case in texas a wrongful conviction for
murder
in texas and how we use probabilistic
genotyping
[Music]
to analyze the dna evidence and help
exonerate this
individual so probabilistic genotyping
is a kind of a new tool in our tool set
for forensic dna analysts
and it's really helped reduce the
subjectivity
in the way that we interpret dna
mixtures in criminal cases
so this case
[Music]
pertains to the conviction of a man
named lydell grant
for murder in texas and this is um
lydell when he was arrested for murder
in houston texas and primarily
evidence that was used against him
during his trial and i'm going to go
through a background
of the case was eyewitness
identification
and flawed dna mixture interpretation
and i say faulty eyewitness
identification because as
anybody that studied criminal justice
and eyewitness identification we know
that it's notoriously
unreliable especially when the
the eyewitness the race or ethnicity of
the eyewitness
and the race or ethnicity of the
perpetrator
are different and in this case the
perpetrator lydell is obviously
african-american and the eyewitnesses
for caucasians and then flawed dna
mixture interpretation
this is not the actual dna mixture that
was used in this case but
for those of you that are not familiar
with what a dna mixture looks like on an
electropharogram
so this if you look on the far
left hand side of the screen under mr
grant's photo
you see the
the dna locus or dna marker named d3s
1358 that's one of the
dna markers that we analyze and across
the top of this
across the line where d3s 1358 is you
see vwa
d16 csf etc those are the names of the
dna markers tested
and then if you look under each under
each dna marker name
you see several peaks with a number
underneath each peak
and in a single source sample a dna
sample from one individual or from one
person you would only see
two peaks or one peak under each
dna marker because again we are humans
are diploid organisms so we have two
alleles per locus or four mark
per marker that we test if you have two
different alleles at a particular dna
marker you would see
two peaks on the electroferogram and if
you have two of the same alleles if
you're homozygous for that marker
you would see a single allele so
obviously in this
image i'm showing you an example of a
dna mixture there's
far more than two peaks two allele peaks
underneath
each dna marker that's tested and that's
because there's more than
one individual dna present in that
mixture
and that this type of scenario of a dna
mixture
is what was part of some of the key
evidence
used to convict mr grant so
just a little bit of background on the
case
this is aaron shearhorn he's the
stabbing victim in this case
and the murder again happened in houston
texas
in an area of houston called the
montrose district
and it basically is a like a
nightclub bar restaurant district
in houston and it's particularly well
known
for the for being a club and bar
district for the homosexual community
in houston so when mr sharehorn was
murdered
and stabbed to death in the parking lot
outside of this bar
a lot of you know the media got a hold
of it and of course they were calling it
a hate crime
because of his sexuality in the area of
town
where he was killed so essentially um
mr sherhorn had was not actually inside
the club
he had been out and about in the monto
montrose district that night uh in
december 2010
and he had encountered an
african-american male they got into
a fight he had been stabbed multiple
times at that point
he got away from the perpetrator and was
running from him and he actually ran up
to the door
of club blur as you can see in this
image
and there were two bouncers standing at
the door
and they uh he begged them he lifted up
his shirt to show the bouncers that he
had been stabbed and he was begging them
to let him inside um for sanctuary you
know to
to be protected because this um
perpetrator was still chasing him
the bouncers did not let him inside the
club and
while they were arguing about letting
him in the perpetrator caught
up with mr shearhorn and proceeded
to stab him to death in the parking lot
of the club
and there were several eyewitnesses that
were standing
around in the parking lot outside of
club blur
and they witnessed the stabbing and i
will say that
you know one of the things that that
disturbed me about this case
other than that this man had clearly
been stabbed
in his abdominal area and they wouldn't
let him inside the club for safety
is that there were a half dozen or so
eyewitnesses
that watched his
watched him get stabbed to death
essentially in the parking lot and no
one tried to intervene and help him
nor did they try to detain the attacker
so the attacker ran off and was never
caught they did call 9-1-1
and of course mr sherhorn
died died shortly thereafter
so then how does lydell grant
come into play here because i told you
that the witnesses did not
try to detain the perpetrator nor did
they try to help mr sherhorn
so about a week later after the murder
occurred
one of those eyewitnesses that watched
the stabbing
was at a restaurant at a cafe in the
montrose district in houston
and saw our client lidell grant
and thought hmm you know that looks like
the man that i watched stabbed
aaron shear horn in the parking haunted
parking lot of club blur
last weekend so this individual
followed uh lydell grant out into the
parking lot snapped a photo
of his license plate number and then
reported that to
the crime crime stoppers anonymous tip
line they basically
this individual basically called crime
stoppers and said one of the
eyewitnesses to that murder
that i have that happened in the
montrose district
and i just saw the perpetrator and
here's his license plate number and so
long story short
that's how lydell kind of got
intertwined or even
on the radar of the police for this case
so um after they
put out a warrant for lydell arrested
him
and charged him with the crime or were
in the process of charging him for the
crime
they did a police lineup and the
eyewitnesses that watched
the murder occur in the parking lot
outside the club
all of them all six eyewitnesses
identified lydell
as the perpetrator so in addition to the
eyewitness identification
during autopsy during the victims
autopsy they collected
the fingernails of the murder victim
because the eyewitnesses had said that
he struggled he fought for his life he
was stabbed multiple times
during this altercation and ultimately
as you can see here this is a screenshot
of the dna mixture that was recovered
from the fingernails
of the murder victim during autopsy
and so part of the case was
okay we've got the six eyewitnesses that
have identified
slidell grant as the perpetrator and
then they wanted
the prosecutor wanted to know is the dna
mixture that was recovered from
underneath the fingernails of the murder
victim is that a mixture of
the victim and lido grant is lydell
grant present in that dna mixture
and this is actually a screenshot of the
final case case file report the dna
summary report
that was used during mr grant's trial in
2011.
and item 12.2.1.1
was a swabbing of the murder victim's
fingernails
and as you can see they're reporting
that it was a dna mixture
that aaron shearhorn cannot be excluded
as a contributor to the mixture which
you would expect because it was his
fingernails you would expect his dna to
be present
and then they've applied a statistic to
that inclusion
and then of course highlighted in yellow
at the bottom
again this is the final report that was
used during lydell's trial
it says no conclusions will be made
regarding lionel grant as a possible
contributor to this dna mixture
so the analyst the dna expert for the
state in this case
basically said this dna mixture is too
complex
i'm not going to attempt to draw any
conclusions so i'm going to call it
inconclusive
we're not going to say lydell lydell
grant's dna is present
underneath the fingernails of the victim
but we're not going to say he's not
present either we're just going to say
inconclusive
the reality is this is
essentially i think this is the
conservative stance that should have
been taken
it should have been an inconclusive
result
um however the way that it was presented
the actual testimony of the expert
during the trial
was a little questionable so when the
prosecutor was asking the dna expert
were you in front of the jury were you
able to
identify lydell grant dean lydell
grant's dna
underneath the fingernails of the murder
victim
she said i wasn't able to do that
i called it inconclusive inconclusive
the dna mixture was too complex
which was fine but then the prosecutor
went a step further and i'm paraphrasing
some here but it was something to the
effect of oh well you can't say he's not
in there that's correct
and she basically agreed with that and
so it kind of left the door
open in the minds of the jury that oh
well she's not saying
lidell grant's dna is not there it could
be there
could very well still be there and then
you add that
on top of the fact that there were six
eyewitnesses that testified
and visually identified mr grant and as
you can imagine
that was enough to fail his conviction
so again you've got six eyewitnesses
that are saying
um lydell grant was the man that stabbed
aaron shear horn to death
now at this point um when i'm reviewing
the case logs i was the dna consultant
on this case
you know part of me also was wondering
other than
those of us that work in the criminal
justice field know that
eyewitness identification is flawed it's
not very reliable
the other thing that popped into my head
here was you know this was a murder that
occurred in a parking lot of a bar
on a saturday night and so these
eyewitnesses
very likely probably were under the
influence of alcohol so if you tack
if you tack on the um the intoxication
the alcohol intoxication on top of just
the general
unreliability of eyewitness
identification to begin with
you know that's one of the things that
makes this even more
troubling that mr grant was convicted
solely
on eyewitness identification by
eyewitnesses that likely
were intoxicated at the time they were
witnessing the crime
so i got involved in this case
as a consultant in early 2019
so mr grant was convicted again i'll
remind you in 2011. so he had already
been
in prison for several years and
during the time that mr grant was
imprisoned there were there was quite a
bit
of study being done at the federal
government level
and by independent group independent
groups of experts
where we were looking into all the
different disciplines in forensic
science and assessing
the reliability and the validity of the
methods that we were using
in criminal trials and in 2009
actually this was obviously a little bit
before
mr grant's conviction there was a report
called strengthening forensic science in
the united states that path forward
that was published by the national
research council in the national academy
of sciences and it basically kind of was
an overview
of the different disciplines in the
current state of the different forensic
science disciplines and how we could
improve upon our current methods
and then in 2016 september 2016 there
was a
pretty influential publication that came
out
it's called the p cast report and peak
has stands for
the president's council of advisor on
science and technology
and this was a council of experts that
were put together
scientific experts that were put
together under president obama's
administration
again building upon what the
nrc and national academy of sciences
report said it basically said
you know we've got room for improvement
in our
forensic science methodology and
this pcas report you know it's a pretty
long report but
as far as how it relates to this current
case
one of the areas of weakness
that they identified as far as dna
forensic dna analysis
is in how we interpret forensic dna
mixtures
so the report was basically saying that
our forensic science our forensic dna
technology the instrumentation we're
using
the laboratory methods that we're using
to generate the results
are valid and reliable but
where we could stand for some
improvement is
is in how we interpret the data that we
generated in the laboratory
and so you know i've i've shown you a
screenshot here one of the statements
from this report was complex dna mixture
analysis
needs additional support to be deemed
scientifically valid and reliable
and you know this was late 2016.
again mr grant's already in prison um
for murder and they just keep this pcast
report keeps getting a lot of press
and so i've highlighted down at the
bottom of the screen here you know this
study aimed to help close the gaps for a
number of what are called forensic
feature comparison methods so again this
report was not just an
overview of the current state of
forensic dna analysis but a lot of other
forensic science methods like how we
compare dna samples
bite marks latent fingerprints
firearms and ballistics footwear
patterns
hair analysis etc
and then right after this pcas report
came out forensic magazine which
is geared towards a lot of people that
maybe aren't
working within the forensic science
field but that want to keep abreast of
all the current and latest developments
yeah they published forensic magazine
published a huge article
that says subjective dna mixture
analysis which has been used in
thousands
of cases across the u.s has been blasted
by a white house panel and again that
white house
panel is that president's council of
advisors on science and technology that
p
cast council and basically
both the pcas report and this particular
article what they said was again
that um when we
as individual trained forensic dna
analysts
try to interpret a dna mixture
that's recovered from a victim or a
crime scene there's some level of
subjectivity that goes into that
analysis and that interpretation and
that we need to find
a better way a more objective way to
analyze these dna mixtures
and one of the suggestions was that we
move
more in the direction of artificial
intelligence
and we allow computers specifically
computer software programs
to analyze these dna mixtures rather
than us
individually as people trying to analyze
these mixtures to
reduce again that subjectivity
so in the in the process of that p
cash report being developed um remember
that report was published in
late 2016 there were some other things
that were going on
as a result of that 2009 nrc
report and one of the things that
we were doing was auditing
forensic science laboratories criminal
crime labs across the u.s
and kind of assessing how things were
being done in these laboratories and
is it scientifically sound reliable
valid etc
and one of the things that made national
headlines
in april 2015 so about a year before the
pcash report came out
was that there was a big lab in
washington dc
a cream of the crop type lab a high-end
high-level lab that a national
accreditation board
found flaws
in the way that they were interpreting
dna mixtures
and essentially in the bottom right hand
of the screen if you read this
all of these um
casework testing that was being done um
by that lab
once this audit was done the lab was
basically shut down and all the case
work was suspended
because what they found was that the
problems with that lab
had centered on the analysis of evidence
that again includes dna
that's from more than one person and the
conclusions regarding the likelihood
that a certain person's dna is included
in that dna mixture or not
so again we're you know we're further
eliminating as this process is moving
along that there are some
issues with the way we were interpreting
dna mixtures
after this washington dc lab
was shut down and casework
operations were suspended the state of
texas which is where i was working
during this time period
then said whoa you know basically if
if they're doing this incorrectly if
there are weaknesses in the way
dna mixture interpretation is being done
in washington dc i wonder if we have
issues in the state of texas as well
so there was a statewide audit that was
done of all the dna labs
in texas and they wanted to look at you
know how many
cases have already been adjudicated and
how many current cases do we have
where a dna mixture is a key part of the
evidence
that either was used in the original
conviction or acquittal or is currently
being used for the
current probate of cases and what they
found
was that there since 1999 and again this
was 2015
there were over 25 000 cases that were
tried in texas courts that involved
dna mixtures and so they actually sent
a letter to all of the all inmates
or maybe they weren't inmates anymore
and they had been released but anyone
that had been convicted
of a crime in texas where a dna mixture
was involved in their conviction
they sent them letters and basically
said this you know we've since
identified that there are issues with
the way
subjectivity issues with the way dna
mixtures are interpreted and this
hence maybe grounds for an appeal for
you or a new trial
and so this was i mean this was huge in
the state of texas again here's another
article
um that was published in texas texas
reviewing thousands of dna cases that
used outdated methods for calculating
odds
and again this was august 2016 about a
month before the pcas report came out
again that they were building on um
the washington dc audit and the 2009
nrc report and you know we just realized
with interpretation comes subjectivity
and anytime there's subject subjectivity
involved
in interpreting a dna mixture we can
make errors we can potentially
you know prosecute the wrong person
convict the wrong person or even
possibly the flip side of that
is acquitting the wrong person
so as far as subjectivity with this big
statewide audit in texas what we found
was
um that different dna labs across the
state of texas were using different
methods or different approaches
to interpret dna mixtures to recover
from crime scenes
there was a lack of standardization
as far as how to go about analyzing and
interpreting a dna mixture
the obvious like in murder cases such as
this case
and maybe rape cases there you would
expect the victim's dna to be present in
the mixture and logic would tell you you
can subtract
the known dna profile of the victim out
of the dna mixture
and therefore helped deduce the profile
of the
perpetrator that was not necessarily
being done
across the board throughout labs in
texas
and then part of this statewide audit
was to
take complex dna mixture cases from
various labs across the state of texas
and make copies of the dna mixtures that
were used in this trial
disseminate those out to
several different highly qualified dna
analysts
and ask them to independently review and
interpret the mixtures
and what we found was is when you give
the same a copy of the same dna mixture
to several different
highly competent dna analysts many times
the different analysts
independently would come to different
conclusions about whether someone was
included or
excluded from that mixture so
um obviously just just as an example
here
i'll show you one of the things that we
were doing before
probabilistic genotyping is
um we were doing interpretation of dna
mixtures based on what we call the
major contributor minor contributor
scenario
where the height of the dna peak in an
electrophorogram
is correlated to the amount of dna
present so
in a lot of these cases where you would
expect the victim's dna to be present
under their own fingernails
or if it's a rape case where it's a
vaginal swab you
would expect a lot of the victim's dna
to be present
and therefore the peaks would be higher
and maybe less
dna from the perpetrator would be
present and that would be your minor
contributor and so
if we were looking at a dna mixture we
thought visually this is a clear major
minor contributor scenario we were again
trying to manually interpret that
mixture
and in this case um if you look at this
slide i've got
marker one so this is showing you an
example of an electro paragraph for four
different dna markers
tested if you look at the two peaks
under
marker number one many analysts
would interpret this
as being one person in this dna mixture
has
two copies of allele a
and in under marker three because of the
height of the peak this person has two
copies of allele b
because recall from earlier in this
presentation
that when you have two of the same
alleles that peak sits on top of each
other and it increases the height of the
peak
because there's more copies of that a
little present
um so many analysts would you know
interpret
that part of the mixture on under marker
number four
many analysts would say well the height
of the peaks for allele a
and allele d are higher so that's
clearly the major contributor
and the peak for the allele b and c
under marker four are the minor
contributors so that's how they would
pair the alleles together and separate
the mixture into dna profiles for two
individuals
but you know this can get again when you
when you have multiple different people
looking at
the same dna mixture this can
you can arrive at different conclusions
there's some subjectivity so for the
second marker
many analysts would say okay one
individual in this mixture for this
marker
has an allele a and a we'll see
for marker number three same thing you
know some analysts may say
the major contributor is bb and the
minor contributors
ac for marker four again
a lot of analysts would say there's a
clear major minor contributor there
but then you go back over to the first
marker on the far left hand side of the
screen
and even though most trained dna
analysts would have agreed that the
major contributor in this scenario
has two copies of allele a
when they were deducing the allele
pairings for the minor contributors
some analysts may say they have two
copies of the b
allele and other analysts may say
well i think they have one copy of the a
allele and one
b and then if you look underneath the
second marker
there's several different scenarios
there that different analysts could
arrive at as far as what the allele
pairings are for the minor contributor
so and of course keep in mind that in in
standard case work we're analyzing now
20 different dna markers and you're
going to go through this process for
each marker in the dna profile
and so it's a lot more than just the
four markers that i've shown you on the
screen
in other scenarios so on the previous
slide i was
explaining to you kind of what we
considered in the field a
clear major contributor clear minor
contributor scenario or relatively
straightforward
but the reality is that's not what a lot
of mixtures were looking like
in criminal cases you might in other
words do something
like this where the peak heights are
pretty similar between the peaks for
each marker tested
and so there's no discernible major
minor contributor
so at that point you know and i'll go
back to that slide it gets even
a little more complex in how you're
subjectively
determining which two alleles pair with
which person
for each marker tested so what the
nrc report and the pcash report
basically said
is that we need a better way to do this
we need a better way
to interpret complex dna mixtures
and there's too much subjectivity
involved
with people no matter how well-trained
you are how intelligent you are
so let's let computers do it for it
and so there were software programs
developed to help
interpret complex dna mixtures and need
software programs
do what's called probabilistic
genotyping
where in and i'll go back to this
previous slide
the software programs are looking at
peak heights and various
key components of the electrophilogram
and calculating the probability
of each allele pairing up with another
allele to deduce
the proper what the highest probability
is that
of which allele should be paired
together in this mixture so that you can
deconvolute
the mixture of dna profiles into
separate
individual profiles and two of the
the big probabilistic genotyping
software programs that are currently
being used in casework labs
one is called star mix and the other one
is called true allele
and they both they basically both do the
same thing
um they both are interpreting dna
mixtures based on probabilistic
genotyping
and again it's the less subjective we
can never
completely reduce the subjectivity in
dna mixture interpretation because again
it's a blind process
you know we often say that forensic
science is a historical science because
we are
as analysts we're actually analyzing the
remnants of a crime
we're not actually present when the
crime's being committed when that dna
mixture is being formed so we have to
analyze the data after the fact and
that's what these software programs do
and again the less objective less
subjective approach is what we were
shooting for because we're also dealing
with some
unconscious bias sometimes with human
analysts
but the previous way we were doing it
again involved
calculation of what's called a cpi or
cpe
combined probability of inclusion or
combined probability of
exclusion um we have abandoned that
approach now
again and we're using these computer
software programs so we still have the
human dna analyst that is
extracting the dna from the evidence
doing all of the laboratory work to
generate the dna profiles but once
once the dna mixture profile is
developed and produced
then we're letting a computer software
program
analyze the data instead of us
doing it as human so i'll take you back
to
this previous slide in the presentation
where
recall that at the time of mr grant's
original trial in 2011
they had a dna mixture that was
recovered from the fingernails
of the murder victim and they were not
able to
draw any conclusions about whether mr
grant was included or executed from that
mixture
so they just called it inconclusive and
so
in february 2019 is when i started
consulting on this case and of course
i'm familiar with the nrc report the
pcash report etc
so i thought okay well maybe you know
this technology was not available to
interpret dna mixtures at the time of
the trial but let's
see what these probabilistic genotyping
software programs will say
now about whether mr grant
is included or exploited from that
mixture
so before i sent
the raw data that was originally
generated back in 2011
for probabilistic genotyping analysis i
thought let me just do
kind of a quick screen let me take that
dna mixture
that was produced from the evidence in
2011 and let me just
list the alleles in a basic excel
spreadsheet
and this is what i did so just kind of
at first glance what does it look like
could he be possibly in this mixture
could he not
and you'll see here so on the far left
hand of the screen
you'll see a column called locus that's
the name of the dna marker
that was tested you've got lydell grants
individual dna profile that we obtained
from his reference sample
we've got the in the third column the
victims dna profile
from their reference sample and then
[Music]
the subsequent six columns are the
alleles that were present in that dna
mixture
and what i wanted to see was obviously
is we would expect the victim's dna to
be present in there but
is are there some common alleles with
lionel grant
and what i started seeing was just on
this initial screening
um of course this is not the way we
analyze dna mixtures but this is kind of
a first glance
approach it was pretty obvious to me
that mr grant his dna is not present in
this mixture so everything that's
highlighted in yellow here for you
and in red color
are alleles that were present in the
mixture
that the dna mixture that was recovered
from the victims fingernails that do not
correspond to alleles in
the victim's dna profile or mr grant's
dna profile and there were 26
what we call foreign alleles that were
present underneath the murder victim's
fingernails that don't match the murder
victim
or mr grant or the suspect the guy that
was convicted of this crime
so i should point out here that this
is something that took me about 30
minutes to do
that could have very easily have been
put together
and shown during lydell grant's original
trial in 2011
that i'll point out that lydell grant
was an indigent
client an indigent defendant he had a
[Music]
public defender defending him and that
public defender did not hire
a forensic dna expert on mr grant's
behalf
so all the jury heard was
what's on this previous slide that there
was a dna mixture recovered
from the murder victim's fingernails and
the dna mixture's too complex we can't
interpret it so we're going to call it
inconclusive
but then of course they heard that there
were six eyewitnesses that identified mr
grant
now with that being said back to this
slide again this took me 30 minutes to
put together
i think even in 2011 before we were
using these
computer software programs to analyze
dna mixtures
had mr grant's attorney hired a dna
expert this
might have and they had posted this up
on the screen
so the jury could see it this might have
planted that reasonable doubt
in the minds of the jury that they had
the
you know whether or not they had the
correct person
this might might have been enough
to plant that reasonable doubt and
remember the burden of proof in a
criminal trial is you have to think that
someone is guilty beyond a reasonable
doubt
there's clearly someone else
present underneath the fingernails of
the murder victim just by looking at
this
basic screening tool so i was working
with
mike ware who's the director of the
innocence project of texas he's a
defense attorney so i call him
he's in texas i'm in connecticut and i
send him a screenshot of this and i'm
like well you know you're right
i don't think lydell is in the mixture
um but
what we need to do based on the current
recommendations of the pcas report
and all the national audits that are
happening is we can't just go with this
we need to now
send this raw data this dna mixture data
and have it analyzed with one of these
probabilistic genotyping software
program
so we sent the raw data to a company
called cyber genetics in pennsylvania
and this company is the developer the
maker
of true allele dna interpretation
software
and what you can do so this is march of
2019
you can submit the dna data
that that contains the data for the dna
mixture as
well as the dna profiles of the victim
and the suspect and they will run it
through their
probabilistic genotyping software and
they will send you back a report
and tell you based on that based on
their software analysis
who's included in the mixture and who's
excluded
and you get it in an email response and
basically you can see here this is
actually a screenshot
of the email that i got back in march
2019 saying
um if you look at the highlighted region
victim erin sherhorn's dna was found on
his fingernails well we knew that
because they are aaron sherhorn's
fingernails but the very next bullet
point there you'll notice
is defendant lydell grant's dna was
not found on the victim's fingernail so
he's
excluded as a contributor to that dna
mixture
and then they go on to state dna from an
unknown person
was found on the victim's fingernails
and they
again subtract the
victim's dna profile out of the mixture
because you know that person's dna
is in the mixture and they essentially
the soccer program essentially deduced
the alleles that are in the dna profile
of the foreign contributor
and um so we got excited at that point
we thought we knew we were moving in the
right direction and that they had indeed
convicted the wrong
person but on top of the email
that you saw in the previous slide that
states who's
included and who's excluded from a dna
mixture
one of the other things that cyber
genetics will do
is they apply a statistical weight
to that inclusion or exclusion and you
can see
item 12.2.1.1 is the victim's fingernail
we also had a dna profile from the
victim
a reference sample a victim or i'm sorry
dna profile
from lydell grant the accused and
they apply a statistical probability so
you can see
this is the exponent that 19 underneath
victim
that's the exponent for the statistical
value so you can see
um um this is somewhere between
obviously the victim's dna is included
somewhere up in the quintillion
septillion
numbers um he's obviously included we
expected that
but look at lydell grant's
reference dna profile he is excluded
um between that billions and trillions
there's 8.5 billion individuals on
planet earth
so this exceeds the popul the human
population of earth
and then the unknown male contributor
who's present in that dna mixture
both the unknown male contributor and
the victim are
determined to be the two individuals in
that mixture they're included in the
mixture
lido grant is excellent so
[Music]
we thought at that point that you know
that was our k
that was our grounds for appeal you know
we've proven that
lidell grant's dna is not underneath the
fingernails of the murder victim
and we contacted the conviction
integrity unit at the houston da's
office
we wanted to move forward with the
appeal
and then the thought process became well
so what
you know aaron shearhorn was
out in the bar district on a saturday
night in houston
um he's a gay man he might have had
a sexual encounter earlier that evening
and that
foreign contributor that unknown dna
profile underneath his fingernails
might not be related to the murder at
all it might be related to
a sexual encounter that he had earlier
that evening
so we knew we had to find out
[Music]
who this dna profile belonged to
so in april of 2019 we worked with
john donahue at beaufort county
sheriff's office in south carolina
to have a to have this unknown dna
profile
that was found in the mixture searched
against the fbi's codis dna database
and we
got results back a couple of months
later in june 2019 that we had a hit
in the codis database and let me remind
you
that the codis the national dna database
maintained by the fbi is vastly
incomplete
because it only contains the dna
profiles of convicted offenders so
people that have been caught
and it contains for some state it
allows us to profile the dna of all
arrestees so people that have been
arrested but not yet convicted
so anybody that hasn't been arrested
hasn't been caught and convicted will
not be in this database so there's a
chance that we could have not
had a hit at all or match in the
database at all
we did get a hit to an individual named
americo carter and
not only had he been in and out of the
prison system throughout his life he's
like habitual criminal
but he was we did some background
investigation on him
he was known to not be incarcerated at
the time mr sheerhorn was murdered
he lived in the houston area where he
where mr sherhorn was murdered during
that time period and he moved away
from houston a couple of months after
the crime occurred
he was actually tracked down in december
in atlanta georgia and arrested
for the murder of mr sherhorn and he has
actually confessed to the crime
so june 2019 is when we identified
jericho
carter as the perpetrator and
it took us several more months after
that to get
lydell grant out of prison so this is an
image
in the top image on the far left that's
mike ware the director of
the innocence project of texas and you
can tell lydell is happy
in this photo this was right when he
found out he
was going to get released from prison
this was the day before thanksgiving so
late november 2019 and then the bottom
photo
is him walking out of the courthouse
after he's been released from prison
and that's his mother and his brother
that he is with
and then so that again he was released
from prison the day before thanksgiving
and then december is when they finally
tracked down at this point we were going
to be preparing for a new trial
for lydell so we could present all the
new
dna evidence probabilistic genotyping
analysis and all the codex hit and
everything
and in the meantime the police were
searching for
jamerrica carter that we identified in
the
fbi's database and these are some
screenshots of some articles that came
out
he was arrested new suspect arrested
charged in 2010 montrose stabbing
wanted murder hid in atlanta for years
while an innocent man
sat behind bars and then i just wanted
to show you
an image here again on the left this is
lydell grant's
mech shot when he was arrested in 2010
and on the far right is jamerrica carter
when he was arrested in december 2019
and you know you can study you can go
back there are multiple instances
throughout history
of where dna has been used to exonerate
someone that was originally convicted
based on eyewitness identification
um and if you end up looking at an image
of the convicted person and the true
perpetrator that was later convicted
there do tend to be some similarities
in the way they look um
as far as this happening and with
wrongful convictions you can look at the
national registry of
since 1989 there have been
2 611 exonerations
and the combined imprisonment time more
than 23
000 years lost the people that were
wrongfully convicted
and i don't you know i'm not going to
spend a lot of time on all of these
steps but
this graph here talks about
um the various contributing factors to
wrongful convictions
and a particularly circled mistaken
witness id
which was a factor in lydell's wrongful
conviction
and false or misleading forensic
evidence again
there wasn't false evidence in this it
just was that there was a dna mixture
recovered
and it was called inconclusive and the
way it was presented in court was
misleading and kind of left the door
open
for the jury to interpret
that he possibly could be in the mixture
and then again compounded with the six
eyewitnesses that identified him that
kind of sealed his state with that
conviction
and so i just want to point out here
lastly that
um you know the the nrc the 2009 nrc
report and the 2016
pcash report were geared towards
they're not pro-defense reports
they are definitely pro-science
pro-justice report
and our goal in the justice system
whether we are
attorneys or forensic scientists should
be
to find the guilty and protect the
innocent we don't want the
cases like this to happen where someone
spends 10 years in prison
for a crime they didn't commit so
um oops sorry so
you know we've we've had this mindset we
need to go back to this there's a 19th
century medical legalist
that said you know if the law has made
you a witness
you must remain a man of science you
can't go into it thinking you have a
victim to avenge
or a guilty or innocent person to
convict or save you have to
bear testimony within the limits of
science
[Music]
i want to dedicate this to a lot of
people
you know they hear about these cases and
they think oh you're just working for
the defense you were working for
lydell grant the convicted the accused
but
ultimately you know this is a
pro-justice
um stance that we took on this case so
i'd like to dedicate
not just the work that we did to this
case but this presentation
not only to lidell grant who was
wrongfully convicted but also to mr
sheerhorn
the victim because we've finally been
able to
get justice for him and his family and
identify the person that
that really committed this crime
and this was a joint effort you know i'm
presenting this as a dna consultant on
this case but i
by far did not work by myself on this
and this was a collaborative effort
between myself
and again i worked for the henry lee
institute of forensic science in
connecticut
the innocence project of texas and then
the justice through science symbol that
you see here on the screen
is one of the logos for cyber genetics
the company
in pennsylvania that developed
trail software
and again this is my queer this was the
team
that worked on liddell and mr sherhorn's
behalf to make sure that
justice was done in this case mike ware
again
is the director of the innocence project
of texas and he also runs the innocence
clinic at the texas a
m school of law and on the far right of
your screen is dr mark purlin
who's the chief scientific officer and
the chief executive officer of cyber
genetics in pennsylvania and he's one of
the developers
of triol technology which again is
the computer software part one of the
computer software programs that we now
use
to analyze complex dna mixtures and it
has greatly reduced
the subjectivity and interpretation
so with that being said thank you very
much for
listening and for attending and have a
good rest of your day
thank you if you have any questions feel
free to reach out